TODD: TEXAS OPERATION LONE STAR
HAS RESULTED IN MORE THAN
5 THOUSAND MIGRANT APPREHENSIONS
AND 3400 RESTS.
JILLIAN: THE PROGRAM WAS LAW
FIRMED JUST THIS MARCH TO COMBAT
THE SMUGGLING OF DRUGS ACROSS
THE BORDER.
KEN PAXTON JOINS US NOW TO
REACT.
YOU LOOK AT THOSE NUMBERS, IS
THAT A SUCCESS TO YOU FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT IS ALLOWING PEOPLE TO
STAY OR GET TRANSPORTED AROUND
OUR STATE OR OTHER PARTS OF THE
COUNTRY.
WE ARE DOING WHAT WE CAN TO
PROTECT OUR CITIZENS AND I
APPLAUD GOVERNOR ABBOTT FOR
INSTITUTING THIS.
IT IS HAVING AN IMPACT BUT WE
CAN’T SOLVE THE PROBLEM BY
OURSELF.
TODD: FEDERAL PART OF ALL OF
THIS HAVE YOU HEARD ANYTHING
FROM THE BIDEN WHITE HOUSE NOW
THAT THE LONE STAR NUMBERS HAVE
BEEN RELEASED?
>> NOTHING.
AND ACTUALLY HAVEN’T HEARD
ANYTHING FROM THEM SINCE THEY
ANNOUNCED DAY ONE THAT THEY WERE
GOING TO ALLOW PEOPLE TO STAY
THEY HAVE BEEN MORE ABOUT
BRINGING PEOPLE IN THAN
PREVENTING PEOPLE FROM COMING.
JILLIAN: HOW MUCH MANPOWER IS
BEING PUT INTO THINK WE ARE
PUTTING MILLIONS AND MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS INTO THIS.
WE HAVE BEEN DOING THIS FOR YEAR
PUTTING MANPOWER ON THE BORDER
TO HELP THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
WE HAVE ADDED MANPOWER.
THERE IS LITERALLY THOUSANDS OF
PEOPLE THAT ARE WORKING FROM OUR
STATE POSITIONS, LAW ENFORCEMENT
TO HELP THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
AND DO WHAT WE ARE DOING NOW,
WHICH IS ARREST PEOPLE ON OUR
OWN.
TODD: A.G. PAXTON, I ASK YOU
THIS EVERY TIME WE HAVE YOU ON.
I’M GOING TO ASK YOU IT TO YOU
AGAIN ALBEIT IN LIGHT OF THE
INITIAL PART OF THE SEGMENT
WHERE YOU REFERENCE THE NUMBER
OF PEOPLE THAT YOU HAVE
APPREHENDED IS THE SITUATION AT
THE BORDER GETTING BETTER OR IS
IT GETTING WORSE?
>> I WISH I COULD SAY IT’S
GETTING BETTER BUT I STILL THINK
IT’S GETTING WORSE.
I THINK THE CARTELS ARE GETTING
MORE AND MORE STRENGTH.
THEIR NETWORKS ARE GETTING
BETTER AND BETTER.
>> THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION HAS
OPENED THE BORDER.
SO THEY’RE GETTING BETTER AT
TRAFFICKING PEOPLE, SEX
TRAFFICKING, HUMAN TRAFFICKING.
THEY MAKE MONEY OFF OF ALMOST
EVERY SINGLE PERSON COME UP.
THEN THEY ARE GETTING BETTER AT
IMPORTING DRUGS AND OTHER
ILLEGAL ACTIVITIES.
SO THEY ARE GETTING ACTUALLY
BETTER AT IT SO, NO.
THE SITUATION IS NOT GETTING
BETTER.
WE ARE NOT DOING THE THINGS THAT
WORKED.
IN THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION TO
STOP THIS.
TODD: SWITCHING GEARS THE RUN
AWAY TEXAS DEMOCRATS ARE GOING
TO TESTIFY AT THE U.S. HOUSE
HEARING TOMORROW.
THE HEARING IS TITLED DEMOCRACY
IN DANGER THE ASSAULTING RIGHTS.
AMERICANS FACING THE MOST
SWEEPING ASSAULT ON THE PASSAGE
OF THE PEOPLE’S VOTING RIGHTS IN
1 5.
>> TEXAS IS GROUND ZERO IN THIS
BATTLE.
WE ARE HONORED TO HAVE THESE
TEXAS LAWMAKERS COME TO TESTIFY
BEFORE OUR SUBCOMMITTEE ABOUT
THE STRUGGLE TO DEFEND BASIC
DEMOCRACY IN THEIR STATE.
SO, AFTER THIS HEARING, ONCE
THIS PUBLICITY STUNT IS OVER,
WHEN DO YOU GUYS ACTUALLY HAVE
THIS VOTE ON THE BILL?
>> WELL, IT’S GOING TO HAPPEN.
IT’S JUST A MATTER OF WHEN THEY
WANT TO COME BACK TO TEXAS.
AND I’M ASSUMING THAT SOME DAY
THEY WOULD LIKE TO COME BACK TO
TEXAS.
THE REALITY IS THE IRONY OF THIS
IS THAT THEY ARE THE ONES
STOPPING VOTING.
THEY ARE THE ONES THAT ARE
PREVENTING THE DEMOCRATIC
PROCESS FROM WORKING.
AND SORT OF THE GUISE OF
PROTECTING VOTING.
THE REALITY IS THIS BILL IS
ACTUALLY EXPANDS VOTING IN MANY
DIFFERENT WAYS.
IT ALSO TRIES TO PREVENT FRAUD.
THERE IS A BALANCE TO THE BILL
EVENTUALLY THEY’RE GOING TO COME
BACK AND WE’RE GOING TO HAVE A
VOTE.
JILLIAN: OKAY.
WELL, KEEP US UPDATED ON
EVERYTHING.
LOVE TO HEAR ATTORNEY GENERAL
KEN PAXTON.
TODD: I DID HAVE A FOLLOW-UP.
DID YOU SEND THEME CARE PACKAGE
WITH SALSA.
>> I THINK I WILL JUST WAIT
UNTIL THEY GET BACK.
JILLIAN: DR. PEPPER AND HARD
CANDY.